new details are emerging about the slow
police response to the mass shooting at
a school in uvalde texas investigators
say the school police chief who was said
to be leading the response was not
carrying a radio at the time of the
attack
this latest revelation comes as three
more victims of the attack were laid to
rest friday and with pressure mounting
from democrats and gun reform advocates
that congress enact new gun laws a
bipartisan group of senators has
intensified talks behind the scenes this
week hoping to find common ground but
expectations are low
for any significant changes
christina raffini is at the white house
with the latest on this christina good
morning
good morning jeff well as the sun set
here in washington yesterday the white
house lit up orange in honor of national
gun violence awareness day and wear
orange weekend but the country is hyper
aware of the consequences of gun
violence the question remains what if
anything are lawmakers going to do about
it
from brooklyn new york it's crazy how
us children see the problem with gun
violence but yet adults stand by and do
nothing when adults have more power to
long beach california and suburban
maryland
students walked out of class to demand
action on gun violence the people who
run this country don't seem to care
about us just do something
for god's sake do something after making
a prime time plea to congress thursday
night president biden said yesterday
he's closely tracking senate
negotiations and i've been constantly
briefed i'll do what i can to try to see
if we have some real progress on the
table raising the age of purchase for
assault style weapons increasing school
safety and bolstering red flag laws but
there's republican resistance to some of
the proposals hopefully we can find a
way to come together
and make some progress on this
horrendous
problem consistent with our constitution
and with our values and with continued
calls for congressional action from the
white house to the schoolhouse
now is the time for my
republican colleagues to put up or shut
up it's
that simple even the vice president said
friday she's not overly optimistic when
sandy hook happened nothing happened but
you know i do believe that people can
learn and i do believe that people can
revisit an issue like this and perhaps
have a change of heart in mind
now the house judiciary committee did
manage to advance a more strict gun
control reform bill one that has
virtually no chance in the senate senate
majority leader chuck schumer said if
the negotiators seem close to a deal
he's going to give them the time they
need to get there if not he wants
everyone on the record on these issues
and could hold a vote as soon as next
week dana
those school house voices may not be
able to vote yet christina but hard to
not hear the words that they are saying
thank you